Researchers at Northwestern University have
created a new material they call
hyperelastic bone.
It can be 3D printed and used by surgeons
to treat injuries almost as soon as the printer
finishes.
Once inserted, this material acts as a structural
element and a scaffold for bone regeneration--in
animal models it encourages new bone cells
to move in and rebuild the injured area.
This means it should help human patients regrow
damaged or missing bone.
It’s also cost-effective and easy for surgeons
to customize and deploy.
Hyperelastic bone consists of hydroxyapatite,
the mineral in bone, suspended in an elastic
organic polymer.
It’s flexible, which makes it easy to put
in place.
But it’s also sturdy, and should hold up
until the real thing grows in.
Hyperelastic bone can be printed at room temperature
and handled immediately.
It’s flexible enough that surgeons can cut
it down to fit the patient during the operation.
This material’s effectiveness and ease of
use set it head, shoulders, knees, and toes
above the rest of the field.